Mars is a disappointing hell hole
lacking practically everything we need
to stay alive it looks like we'll only
ever have small Crews spend a miserable
time hidden underground
except we could terraform it into a
green new world
but to solve the planet's problems we
first need to make it worse and turn it
into oceans of lava with gigantic lasers
this isn't a far-fetched science fiction
tale terraforming Mars is possible on
the kind of time scale our ancestors
built great monuments in if Humanity
solves some of its pressing problems and
Ventures into space to expand into the
solar system this may not be that far
off
okay so how do we terraform Mars quickly
well it's complicated
[Music]
Mars is dry and has no soil to grow
anything its atmosphere is too thin to
breathe or protect us from radiation
giving you a high risk of cancer so to
turn it into a new home for Humanity we
have to give it a proper atmosphere
similar to Earth
it should be made of 21 oxygen 79
nitrogen and a tiny bit of CO2 as an
average temperature of 14 degrees
Celsius and under one bar of pressure we
have to create oceans and rivers and
then the ground has to be weathered to
intervert our soul to host living things
then we need to install a biosphere on
the surface and prevent it all from
being undone by installing protective
measures that can stand the test of time
it is difficult but a big laser makes it
a lot easier
challenge one the atmosphere
some 4 billion years ago Mars had a nice
oxygen-rich atmosphere and was home to
vast oceans and rivers
it held on to it for several hundred
million years before it got blown away
ultraviolet rays broke down the
atmospheric gases and then the oceans
until they were Swept Away by solar wind
today Mars is a dry Barren Wasteland
luckily a sizable portion of the water
is Frozen in deep reservoirs and in the
polar ice caps enough to create a very
shallow ocean and enormous amounts of
oxygen are bound as minerals in the
Martian rocks like the oxygen in the
iron oxides that give the planet its
rust red color as well as carbon dioxide
in carbonates
to free these gases we need to reverse
the reactions that lock them away by
using thermolysis which occurs at
temperatures as high as on the surface
of the Sun in short we want to melt the
surface of Mars
the best way to do that would be to put
lasers in orbit aiming their beams down
on Mars the most powerful laser today is
the Eli NP able to produce beams of 10
petawatts of power for a trillionth of a
second
to melt Mars we need a laser twice as
powerful that runs continuously the
easiest way is to use a solar pumped
laser that can be powered directly with
sunlight
it's core our metal infused glass rods
that absorb energy and release it as a
laser beam
we build an array of mirrors in space
about 11 times the size of the United
States we can focus enough sunlight onto
them to melt Mars let's do it as the
lasers hit the surface about 750
kilograms of oxygen and some carbon
dioxide emerge from every cubic meter of
rock melted if we are efficient our
lasers only need to melt through the top
eight meters of the surface to get
enough oxygen it would look terrifying
the skies would be shrouded in storms
where the ground would glow red hot
crisscrossed by currents of lava Tyler's
laser beam sweep over the landscape
leaving trails too bright to look at
after they pass the ground cools quickly
a strange snow falls the ashes from all
the elements that solidify as they cool
down like Silicon and iron Mars is still
a cold Planet at this point a happy side
effect of this Inferno is that all the
water in the polar ice caps and even
deep underground Rises into the sky as
hot steam forming clouds that rain down
over the entire planet they would wash
out the nastier gases from the
atmosphere like chlorine and carry away
harmful elements that accumulated on the
surface
in the end they would form shallow
oceans saltier than on Earth we might
need to do an extra cleanup afterwards
it would take about 50 years of
continuous lasering to create our oxygen
atmosphere we could use this opportunity
to dig deeper in some places to create
the basins for salty oceans or rivers
and spare some Landmark features like
Olympus Mons and Valles marineris
we're not done though
the resulting atmosphere is nearly 100
oxygen and only 0.2 bar it's hard to
breathe and very flammable to make it
similar to Earth and a lot safer we need
to add a lot of nitrogen which Mars is
sadly lacking we have to import it the
ideal source is Titan a large Moon of
Saturn covered in a thick atmosphere
that's almost entirely nitrogen we just
have to move three thousand trillion
tons from the outer solar system to Mars
while that's not easy it is doable
to process that much of Titan's
atmosphere we have to construct giant
automated factories on its surface
powered by our lasers to suck in the
atmosphere and compress it into a liquid
this gets pumped into bullet-shaped
tanks which amass driver shoots all the
way to the red planet where they explode
and mix with the oxygen we've already
been able to send individual missions to
Saturn in just a few years with enough
resources it should be possible to
complete the task within two generations
of course it would be much more
convenient to have nitrogen left over
from terraforming Venus on the site we
explained this in detail in another
video
so about a century after the start of
the terraforming process we have a
breathable atmosphere that has the right
gases if the liberated CO2 isn't enough
to warm it up to temperatures we can
stand we just adds some super greenhouse
gases Mars at this point resembles a
black marble through all the cooling
lava spotted with growing oceans and red
patches where the old surface remains
untouched it's still a wasteland no
better than a desert on Earth
we need to fill it with life
challenge 2 biosphere
installing a biosphere on a new planet
is very difficult unexpected
interactions between species or sudden
diseases can destabilize it to the point
of collapse we would probably Begin by
seeding our young oceans with
phytoplankton without competition it
would Bloom rapidly filling up the
oceans to become the bottom of an
aquatic food chain
they can be followed by tiny zooplankton
then by fish maybe even sharks and
whales if things go well life in the
oceans will thrive
life on land is harder plants need
nutrient-filled ground to sink their
Roots into but most of the surface is
the congealed remains of lava and Ash we
could wait for thousands of years for
water and wind to grind it down into
finer Sands or try to do it manually but
we want to be quick and we have a big
laser
turning the beam on and off in Rapid
succession would cause the ground to
quickly heat up and contract which
breaks it into smaller and smaller
pieces
add a bit of water and you get a sort of
dark mud into this mud we can mix fungi
and nitrogen fixing bacteria they're
able to absorb nitrogen and convert it
into nitrate compounds to feed plants
the first plants we want to bring are
native to volcanic islands on Earth
since they're perfectly suited to the
laser blasted Martian landscape
eventually the enriched mud becomes the
foundation for grasslands and forests in
Mars's lower gravity trees can become
very tall very fast their Roots gather
the nutrients they need and then dig
deeper to turn more rocks into soil
forming a self-sustaining ecosystem
at this point we can slowly introduce
more plant varieties insects and animals
not mosquitoes though the new biosphere
needs to be maintained to prevent it
from falling out of balance If plants
grow too quickly and absorb too much
carbon dioxide the planet cools down too
much if key species die out we could see
populations collapse faster than they
could recover
on Earth other species would move in to
fill the void but our Martian biosphere
is not as flexible it takes hundreds if
not thousands of years before Mars
becomes a stable environment
but eventually the planet will have the
potential to sustain large human
colonies with air water and food
available we can finally call Mars black
blue and green Our Hope a giant volcanic
island in space
will it last though
Challenge 3 the long-term future
there is a problem we haven't addressed
Mars's core does not produce a magnetic
field so it doesn't have enough
protection from solar radiation or
cosmic rays this becomes dangerous for
the long-term health of Martian
populations so as a final step we need
an artificial magnetic field
it doesn't have to be huge like Earth's
it just needs to deflect the solar wind
enough so that it doesn't touch Mars the
easiest way is to construct a magnetic
umbrella far ahead of Mars that splashes
the solar wind to the sides a big
superconducting ring powered by nuclear
facilities is all it takes
it would orbit at the Mars Sun L1 Point
keeping it constantly in between the Sun
and Mars and protect the new atmosphere
and that's it terraforming Mars would
take some work Hefty resources and
probably a century or 10 but it would be
the first time we've lived in a home
designed and shaped solely by us and for
us the first step towards our future
Among the Stars
the first step that we can already take
down here on Earth is learning more
about the physics and biology needed for
such a project to help you with that
we've created a series of lessons to
build your fundamental understanding of
these topics made in collaboration with
our friends at brilliant.org these
lessons give you a deeper understanding
of the topics from our most popular
videos from super volcanoes to black
holes to climate science brilliant is an
Interactive Learning tool that makes
maths science and computer science
accessible with a Hands-On approach
because we know that to really learn
something you've got to do it think of
each lesson as a one-on-one tutoring
version of a quartz Gazette video in our
latest lesson you'll learn more about
how Mars lost its atmosphere and how we
might protect a terraformed Mars from
suffering the same fate brilliant has
thousands of lessons to explore from
math space topics like algebra and
probability to the concepts behind
algorithms and machine learning and with
new lessons added each month including
ones from course gazat you'll always
find something fascinating to learn to
get Hands-On with kotzgaz art lessons
and explore everything brilliant has to
offer go to brilliant.org Nutshell and
sign up for free today
there's even an extra perk for kusks out
viewers the first 200 people to use the
link get 20 off their annual membership
which unlocks all of brilliant's courses
in maths science and computer science we
love seeking New Horizons with our
research brilliant will be the Catalyst
to expand the limits of your knowledge
[Music]
foreign